parole est un monsieur guillaume larrivé
pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
permettez-moi une confidence il est
parfois assez difficile de comprendre
quelle est la logique et la cohérence de
votre politique économique budgétaire et
fiscale il ya quelques jours vous avez
vous même déclaré que françois hollande
et jean marc ayrault avait au début du
quinquennat provoquer je vous cite des
dégâts considérables
merci de cet aveu et de ce premier
éclair de lucidité mais depuis que vous
êtes premier mini ça continue il ya 14
milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaires qui sont prélevés en
2014 et en 2015 sur les ménages un
bombardement fiscale qui affaiblit la
france qui tue les entreprises et qui
appauvrit les classes moyennes et ya
pire
un véritable festival budgétaire et
fiscale connaît chaque jour des épisodes
de plus en plus originaux
le ministre du budget pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république demande à certains
contribuables de ne pas payer les impôts
qu'il a lui même demandé la ministre des
collectivités locales demandent aux
députés de rejeter la réforme de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
qu'elle a lui même présenté et ce matin
le porte parole du gouvernement demande
en réalité que nous rejetons la réforme
de l'allocation adulte handicapé que
vous même vous proposer la vérité
monsieur le premier ministre c'est que
nous assistons éberlué à une sorte de
happening permanent ou ce qui est
annoncé le matin et contredit l'après
midi avant d'être démentie le soir ma
question sera donc très direct monsieur
le premier ministre
y at il un pilote dans l'avion à
l'elysée ou à matignon ou bien monsieur
le premier ministre
est ce que votre méthode de gouvernement
et désormais la godille l'improvisation
et le zig zag permanent merci monsieur
l'arrivée la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur manuel valls
sur le député l'arrivée au final en vous
écoutant que reprochez vous à ce
gouvernement sur un certain nombre de
sujets que vous avez énuméré d'avoir su
écouter la majorité d'avoir entendu la
société lorsque cela était nécessaire
ou peut-être même pire d'avoir sur
réparer vos propres erreurs ce
gouvernement et cette majorité disent la
vérité aux français la vérité sur l'état
du pays celui la situation que nous
avons trouvé en 2012 est de votre
responsabilité et nous disons bien sûr
la vérité sur ce que nous faisons
alors il y a un cap une volonté de
réforme et une détermination avec deux
objectifs très clairs baisser la dépense
publique
vous avez endetté le pays de plus de 600
milliards d'euros baisser les impôts
alors que vous n'a eu de cesse de les
augmenter quand vous étiez au pouvoir
quand sous le gouvernement sarkozy
fillon
la dette publique explose est et les
impôts augmenter donc oui nous réformons
et nous le faisons avec méthode en
respectant l'ensemble des acteurs et des
corps intermédiaires car réforme et
contrairement à ce que vous pensez
ce n'est pas brutalisé et la réforme ça
ne peut pas être la rupture et réformer
ce n'est pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation
réformer c'est la volonté et c'est la
note c'est aussi savoir écouter et c'est
aussi savoir corriger
lorsque c'est nécessaire ce dialogue
nous l'avons avec la société avec les
partenaires sociaux avec le parlement et
réformer monsieur l'arrivée ce n'est pas
brandir sans cesse les mêmes idées et
les mêmes totem ce n'est pas votre
entêtement dont vous avez fait preuve
en dix ans et que vous poursuivez
aujourd'hui avec vos propositions
car disons clairement les choses
l'amateurisme
c'est d'avoir supprimé la demi part des
veuves sans en avoir mesuré les effets
ou pire même enlevé simulant
l'amateurisme monsieur l'arrivée celle
avoir dégradé la dette publique de 600
milliards d'euros en cinq ans et de
prétendre aujourd'hui détenir les
solutions pour l'avenir
l'amateurisme monsieur l'arrivée c'est
d'avoir distribué des cadeaux fiscaux
aux plus aisés
quand l'urgence était de soutenir les
plus modestes les petites entreprises et
notre tissu et industriels et en matière
de finances locales
monsieur l'arrivée l'amateurisme c'est
la réforme improvisé non concertée
idéologique je les ai rappelés hier de
la taxe professionnelle or ce n'est pas
notre conception de la réforme de
l'intérêt général car la responsabilité
lot de responsabilités celles du
gouvernement et de la majorité c'est de
prendre des bonnes décisions pour
préparer l'avenir du pays et parfois
pour réparer les choix politiques du
passé alors il ya une différence entre
nous nous l'assumons
nous réformons pour préserver notre
modèle social parce que les français qui
sont attachés parce que la solidarité
plus que jamais nécessaire et nous
allons démontrer cet après midi avec
myriam el khomri quand nous allons
présenter les grandes perspectives pour
la réforme du droit du travail et vous
ce que vous proposez car plutôt que de
critiquer ces 100 à 150 milliards
d'euros d'économies c'est la fin de
notre modèle social
c'est la fin des priorités sécurité
défense écoles emploi culture et c'est
l'augmentation des impôts ceux qui sont
les amateurs ils l'ont prouvé quand il
gouverner et ceux qui trompent et qui
mentent aux français c'est vous parce
que vous leur dites pas la vérité sur
votre projet
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est un monsieur christophe